una nueva batalla jurídica que el rey
emérito de España Juan Carlos I gana
esta vez en Londres y de manera parcial
porque la justicia británica ha
reconocido que hasta que abdicó en 2014
tenía inmunidad es decir El Monarca no
tendría que responder ante la justicia
por delitos o actitudes delictivas
llevadas a cabo entre 2012 cuando su
expareja sentimental Corina larsen dice
que comenzó el acoso y el espionaje
hasta el momento de su abdicación en
junio de 2014 sin embargo Sí podría ser
juzgado por los actos cometidos desde
ese momento la empresaria acusa al ex
monarca de coaccionarla y acosarla
incluso a través del Centro Nacional de
inteligencia español desde el año 2012
hasta el momento de la demanda en 2020
para que le devolviera unos 65 millones
de euros que supuestamente le habría
donado Juan Carlos I dinero que habría
llegado a manos del emérito por un
regalo del rey de Arabia Saudita en 2008
AB de la abdalá bim
que fue investigado por blanqueo de
capital por la justicia Suiza Aunque
archivado en 2021 recordemos que Juan
Carlos I lleva viviendo desde 2020 en
emiratos árabes Unidos a donde se fue
huyendo de la creciente presión judicial
en España en marzo de este año la
fiscalía española archivó todas las
causas en su contra pese a constatar
varias irregularidades Fiscales que no
podían ser imputadas porque ya habían
prescrito o porque cuando sucedieron el
rey aún estaba protegido por la
inviolabilidad que le otorga la
Constitución española de 1978 a Los
Monarcas del país